yes sir J from one lion to another
because you may have seen yesterday you
could have a new league leader and they
have a new logo Alliance so we're
speaking to for his first national
broadcast incidents becoming leader to
UKIP's new line Henry Bolton morning
Henry Ramon you very much for joining us
and congratulations on your victory
yesterday and just to start off with
really why did you want this job and
when you consider what has happened to
the previously no I did well know you
very well when you consider what had
happened to the previous four in only a
year hmm people might think why not does
he wants it yeah I mean I can understand
them asking me a question I the problem
is and it's irrespective of the previous
leaders we're now at a critical point in
the country's future we are going into
this brexit negotiations with frankly
we're not making much progress and it's
critical that going forward we do say
because the future of this country's
welfare its security its trade its whole
economy people's optimism it's all going
to be based into the future it's going
to be based on the outcome of these
negotiations and how we leave the
European Union and this this party is
obviously the party that brought about
effectively the referendum and its
result and we have a moral obligation to
be constructive in that debate
let's talk second minute but I mean many
people in your party have said rightly I
think that as the party goes forward
into the future you need other policies
other areas to focus other than brexit
so I was just looking at your website
last night and to be honest I was quite
a hard push to find other policy areas
that you're interested in other than
brexit so maybe you could just tell us
quite quickly say three policy
initiatives three policies that you
would like to see brought in unrelated
to breakfast no I mean there are they're
all related to brexit in one way or
another we've we've got to have said
publicly before that we're going to go
back to the 2015 manifesto that's the
baseline right okay so that's the start
point right and it's already produced
it's already there now what we're going
to do is we're going to review all of
that so you may have thought
the the 2015 one I believe is a more
appropriate start point to review the
history but to start a review and an
adjusting from that that baseline now
just to go back to the previous question
about all the what I was making about
brexit it is not just about leaving the
European Union that's my point if if we
do not set ourselves up as a nation
internally and externally in our
outwards approach to other nations
we don't set that up in the right way as
we go into the brexit situation into
leaving the European Union we are not
going to be at the best start point to
launch our own independent future if you
like so literally there are three other
issues that you could naval or just
another issue that's unrelated exit
something like a politician last night
I've made it very clear that or
yesterday that I believe that we need to
immediately reverse cuts to border force
and we need to we need to develop a
national border strategy so now it's
about trade facilitation it's about
security okay so just a few quick fire
questions and just to try and flesh out
your politics of it in the past your
party has said that it's in favor of a
referendum on the death penalty is that
something that you would be in favor no
we don't we've got other priorities
there we're not going down that route
not the moment okay and an immigration
cap what do you think immigration should
be roughly this country something you
look what you said you said you base one
there's a base not no I I mean you know
we need a point system and it needs to
be flexible enough to deal with the
different needs and demands on the
nation and on the immigration situation
globally your pocket used to say fifty
thousand I'm not gonna put a figure on
it what I would like to see is that what
is the problem is the problem that we're
not at zero or is the problem that we
have an immigration rate that is higher
than we can actually manage as a nation
that is overwhelming our public services
and it is overwhelming our communities
it's now that that becomes a problem and
it you can't set a figure on that and
stick with moving away from the 2015
manifesto on the death penalty
2015 than well it's too quite for
talking about for taking brexit do you
think there should be any transition
period for this country as really the
European Union I don't think there
should be no absolutely not however the
government at the moment has failed to
plan a prepare for the day that we leave
the European in particular the customs
union okay now there are gonna be heavy
demands on our borders that day that we
leave and no planning on preparation is
taking place now that takes time so if
you need to recruit additional border
force staff if you need to to design or
identify the needs design and then build
additional facilities for example this
takes time now because the government's
already lost 14 months then indeed there
may well be a need to push that forward
no powers used to say no no the parents
to say then it wouldn't be a problem if
we leave on World Trade Organization
rules do you agree with that Hey
not entirely we can do it but it's not
as simple let's do it thanks from the
old view Kimberly Nigel Nigel oh you
won't believe it yeah not sure but your
former leader Nigel Farage the man who
basically endorsed you for this yeah
used to say that the says there should
be no transition period he says the
world trade organizer
so there should be a transition I've
said the should not be should shall be
however I do not want on a point of
principle to say there should not be and
as a result we have a car crash on our
borders so I'm sure it's not different
okay just don't know you watch me should
the be yes just okay just funder and I
don't actually water this is candidate
yeah you described I think there's no
secrets that you essentially said that
you thought that if the party chose her
the party risk becoming a Nazi Party do
you think that there are Nazis in your
party now anything no there was a danger
of it going down the path of being a
national socialist party yes and I know
and III would stand by that but we
yesterday you saw that the party quite
decisively so I did not to go down that
path yeah and I was at least but Nigel
Farage says that he hopes that she
leaves the party do you agree that's
entirely is her decision entirely her
decision
do you like the Lunik new logo is it
here to stay i I quite like it but we
have to appreciate that it's its logo is
about the identity
of the party and that's the matter also
for the members the members yesterday
voted very strongly to adopt the new
logo
so that's do you keep like oh yeah I
don't think it will be yes right we
might tinker around with it a little bit
okay the new you keep leader trying to
rescue his party from why I think today
has been something of a political
irrelevance over the past six months or
so very interesting to see how he does